[Music]
hi everybody my name is Geoffrey Noer
product manager for cloud storage and
here with me today is my Q senior staff
software engineer who will be joining us
for this for the second half of the
presentation this is about all about
cloud storage so this is our object
store we realize looking at the the
session title the last couple of days
that we actually didn't have the product
name in the title so hopefully all of
you care are here and care about object
storage and we're going to be going
through best practices outlining some of
our most recent changes to storage
classes and also providing some
hopefully some good guidance on how to
make use of the product especially when
it comes to performance so I'll start
out I'll keep them the I'll keep the
marketing content to a bare minimum I
promise just a couple of slides to
introduce a cloud storage but then focus
in on storage classes and how best to
apply them particularly in the case of
content serving then we'll look at the
same thing for the application of
storage classes to conte to compute and
analytics workloads and then finally get
into some meet on performance and
scaling so let's dig into the
introduction up so you know Google cloud
for google cloud cloud storage has been
really one of the core storage portfolio
products from the beginning and we've
we've really cared about making sure
that there's a unified experience across
no matter how you use cloud storage so
as you'll hear in the in the storage
classes section that's something that
we've continued to stress with
consistent API is and access strongly
consistent listings have also been part
of the product so it doesn't matter when
you when you list when you upload a
product when you upload objects you'll
as soon as you list them you'll be able
to see the the upload changes there's
there aren't any consistency challenges
the way you might see with with other
cloud storage offerings from from from
other other cloud providers geo
redundancy so all of cloud storage is
built around
global approach to storage so we have
regions dual regions multi regions and
we make it very easy to actually have
your storage distributed with geo
redundancy and then and then finally of
course what you would expect from cloud
scalability no matter whether you need
gigabytes terabytes petabytes exabytes
of storage so this is all made possible
based on the enormous investments that
Google has made in core infrastructure
so you know this this of course started
long before GCP actually existed in this
infrastructure was actually put in place
to support search YouTube Gmail all the
other big properties and then once you
have once you have all these sub C cable
investments and points of presence
globally and the ability to do all of
that content distribution that's the
ideal infrastructure to build a public
cloud solution on top of and so what
you'll see is that we actually have a
great leverage of all of that
infrastructure and continue to bring
onboard new regions some of the most
recent ones include Finland in the
Nordics in Europe we've brought onboard
so Hong Kong turned up relatively
recently Osaka has just just been
announced Salt Lake City so we have new
regions sprouting up everywhere all
connected with very fast networking
infrastructure the three primary use
cases that you'll see for cloud storage
are content storage and delivery and
that leverages the the network that we
just talked about right how do you bring
how do you bring your objects and make
them available globally with high
performance computing and analytics and
machine learning of course are taking a
great amount of interest and Google has
seen it generally as being one of the
the the real leaders in in a in the in
this area and then finally we have a lot
of backup in archiving use cases as well
so here you see just a handful of
household names that that use cloud
storage in each of these areas so let's
dig into now some of the most recent
changes in storage classes so storage
classes really dictate how we place your
data like what regions and and and then
of course what
the the hotness and coldness of the data
how frequently you access it and up
until up until today you actually we've
had a mix of location with with hotness
and coldness of data in the storage
class name so we've had this general key
concept of storage class multi-regional
and regional were both the hottest
classes but those referred to the
locations where we're multi-regional was
was geo redundant and regional locked
down the data to a specific location and
then we had near line and cold line for
for the archival use cases but you could
actually also use those in a regional or
a multi regional location so we felt
like this was actually a little bit
confusing to customers and so we're in
the middle of rolling out changes that
will make this a little bit simpler so
basically what we're looking to do is
we're going to be separating out the
location type from the storage class and
only using storage classes to mean the
the data temperature the frequency of
access so standard is the most
frequently accessed then as the data
gets colder you go to Nearline and then
go to cold line and it's a consistent
set of api's no matter what storage
class you're using and then similarly on
location type this really dictates the
the the amount of geo redundancy and
where your data is stored generally
right so if your sword in a region you
know you'll know that all of your data
is in that specific region if you're in
a multi region you'll be aligned to a
continent so this will generally be for
example the United States the European
Union or the asia-pacific region and
then your data will be at least in two
places somewhere in that continent and
then dual regions are the best of both
worlds where you know exactly where your
data is it's in two specific regions and
that allows you to co-locate your
compute with your storage and if you go
up and down within that stack from
standard to near line to cold line it
the do the geo redundancy is preserved
so in the past near line and cold line
had regional characteristics even if it
was stored in a multi regional location
so that's something that we've improved
as of last October that now the geo
redundant
he stayed skins consistent as you go up
and down within within your buckets oops
so here are examples of regions multi
regions and dual regions going back to
that globe map so the the big green
circles there are straining the US and
the Asia Pacific multi regions there are
two smaller ovals that are dual regions
one in Europe and one in North America
where those are locked down to two
specific regions and then all of the
individual spots there are individual
regions that we provide service in so
why pick a particular location type so
regions offer the lowest possible price
point and are are specifically locked
around one data center so if you have a
jurisdictional reasons for examples too
you want to keep make sure that data
stays in a particular country for
example especially in in Asia or in
Europe
that's one reason popular reason to
choose regional do the other the other
approach is basically for colocation as
you'll hear as we get into the the into
some of the other specific use cases
dual regions keeps it locked down like I
said but with with actually two regions
in the mix that gives you the higher
availability characteristics without
sacrificing the the knowledge that your
data is in specific locations but if you
don't care where your data is you just
want it to be very high availability and
you want to be stored in more than one
region multi region basically gives you
a price cut from dual regions and it'll
and it gives Google the freedom to store
your data in whatever data centers
within that region
as makes sense so particularly for
content delivery we see a lot of use of
multi regions so this is what happens
with data placement if you pick a region
all of your objects end up in that
region so the green boxes here and under
region B assume that you've selected
region B as your region for for that for
that particulars up bucket if you picked
a multi region in the in the red color
I'm here you can see that different
objects they're still in at least
two regions but there it's basically
randomized for prod per object so you
don't really know for any given object
what region they're going to be in but
you know that they're geo redundant
whereas here again in for the dual
region this dual region happens to be
region B and C and so your objects are
always in those two locations so a big
announcement that we made this morning
is that we're actually adding a new
archive storage class so this is
directly aimed at tape replacement needs
and other very long-term other long-term
storage requirements so if you're
planning on keeping your data around for
three five seven ten years don't expect
to access it would have considered to
put it on tape before this is an ideal
solution for the for those sorts of
needs so this really just adds another
tier to the storage classes and
basically you'll be able to go from
storage from standard to near line to
cold line and now to archive and have
really a full suite of storage class
selections for all of your needs and as
you can see we're talking about starting
at at a price point of 0.12 cents so
this is a very appealing price point but
at the same time this is not a storage
class that's glacially slow it has the
same performance characteristics as all
the other storage classes so you don't
need to actually restore data so if you
have 10 petabytes of storage and that
was stored on tape you might be talking
about weeks of time to restore the data
in this case the data is right there
immediate immediately available for your
access you don't have to first restore
it to another bucket under another
storage class to be able to access it
it's available directly out of the the
archive class and we expect that you
know even though this is data that you
don't want to ever access if you do need
to access it like there's a regulatory
reason that you need to suddenly get
your data back and run some analytics
here you won't have to go through a
week-long multi week long period to get
access to your data and it's also stored
with very high durability one of the
problems with tape historically has been
you really have to write it to tape you
have to validate that it's
correctly written and it's often the
case that when people go back to tapes
that they find that their data isn't
there the way they thought it is and
library tape libraries can be very
finicky devices so with cloud storage
and if you select the archive class it's
stored with the same 11 9s durability
that you can come that you've come to
expect from all of our swords classes so
we're very excited about this
announcement archive will be available
later this year so stay tuned for
availability and if you do choose
archived I want to mention in multi
regions or in dual regions same level of
geo redundancy applies as as the other
as the other location types would imply
so it very consistent across consistent
API is consistent level of geo
redundancy so what are the best
practices on selecting the storage
classes so hopefully you've already
you've already selected a location type
that's appropriate for the amount of
availability that you that that your
application cares about but basically
it's a combination of retention period
and access frequency so if you're going
to access data very frequently or if
you're not going to keep it very long
then the standard class is going to give
you the best possible price point
whereas if you're going to store it for
let's say 10 years and never read it
then clearly archive will be the best
choice and in the middle fit near line
and cold line so generally speaking if
it's if you're accessing it less
frequently than once a year and storing
for more than 12 months that's what
we're the new archive classes fits in
but we have a lot of use of near line
and cold line especially for long tail
content archives where they is expected
to be read maybe every month on average
and that's where those middle tiers make
sense and then to unify all of this it's
great to have a consistent API but it's
also useful to have a policy driven
mechanism for for down leveling the
tiers of your storage as the data gets
colder and so we provide that with the
object lifecycle manager you can
basically specify like based on the age
of objects usually that correlates very
well with the free
once you have access so based on your
data set if you understand that in this
example that after 30 days your data
really should move off of standard and
move into Nearline then after 180 then
after 90 days to cold line and then
after half a year to archive you can set
up those policies and then your objects
will automatically or tear down to the
appropriate level and of course because
of the changes that we made with the
with the storage with the location types
your you don't have to worry about
losing durability or losing geo
redundancy as that tearing happens so if
you choose a multi regional location for
example your data will stay G over done
it the whole way down so that means
consistent availability characteristics
and consistent durability so now I want
to talk a little bit about application
of some of these storage classes to
workloads so I'll take you through
content serving and then pass the baton
over to my cool take the presentation
over from there so for content serving
there are actually some interesting
cases we have a lot of customers that do
direct serving but some use cloud CDNs
some use custom front ends but before
serving the data and there also we also
have compelling use cases with our
independent content delivery partners
where they may be taking over the the
last mile distribution and these all can
mean some slightly different things for
what storage class you might ideally
want to select so multi regions see the
most use for direct serving and this is
because if you're serving to either the
whole US or to or even to the whole
globe but you don't really care about
where the data is located you just want
geo redundancy for the highest
availability and you want it to be and
taking advantage of the of all of the
caching that Google makes available so
we have cache control headers that allow
you to state to control that caching but
generally speaking as soon as it as an
object has already been read in a
particular point of presence it will be
cached there and very low latency for
subsequent accesses
so we do encourage you to take an
advantage of the of the cache control
headers for direct serving to optimize
direct serving further you can take
advantage of our cloud CDN product and
what this allows you to do is basically
avoid a lot of the more expensive egress
pricing if it's if you're in the cases
of cache hits so this and the other part
of what this does is it allows you to to
get HTTP and custom domains some
flexibility on the URL side but
fundamentally it just takes the the the
caching capability that's already there
in the base product and gives you a
little bit more capability and some
opportunity for cause some cost savings
on the egress side so that's very
commonly used as part of the direct
serving model so so far that's pretty
much all a multi-regional use case
custom front ends where multi regions
may no longer make sense so this is
where you want to actually put VMs in
front of your content serving because
you're going to manipulate the the data
in some way before it gets sent out to
your customers and in that case the the
overall latency from storage to your
customers access is both the latency
from storage and then the latency from
the VM and so that if you want to
minimize the overall latency it's
important to actually co-locate the
storage with the VMs that are accessing
it so here you want to either use a
region or a dual region to store the
data ideally so that you'll know that
the storage is local to the region in
which it's being accessed by your
front-ends if you want geo redundancy
use a dual region and then you can have
your VMs in both of the regions if it's
very low performance you may still get
away with multi regions so it's not a
hard and fast rule but generally
speaking you might be better off with
regions and dual regions and then you
can also use independent content
delivery networks some of our partners
are shown here on this slide it may be
that they have a particular API is
feature sets that are particularly well
aligned to the market that the content
is being served to it may be that the
particular point pops that they have are
in better alignment there are
or maybe the egress pricing offers some
advantages it depends on the scenario
but we worked very closely with these
partners and and it's it's a great
alternative if if for some reason the
direct serving or our own CDN
capabilities of fall short so here you
would want to use regional or dual
regions again for the same region reason
typically there will be something that's
called an Origin shield that's placed
between Google and the and that CDN
partner and what the origin shield does
is it basically ensures that they that
the cache filling is going to that
origin shield directly from from Google
and it prevents a ton of access from
hitting going back and hitting Google at
the same time so it ends up being the
intermediary between Google and the CDN
partner so if you have that origin
shield layer co-located as closely as
possible with the storage again you you
you help with the overall latency so at
this point I'd like to to pass the baton
to my cue who will take you through the
next section thanks Jeff
okay so we're going to quickly go
through storage class selection in
location type selection for computing
and analytics and then I'll talk a
little bit about some general
performance and scaling tips so one of
the things I think is a little bit
interesting here is that in your
computing it analytics pipelines there's
actually several types of data and your
choice of location type depends on the
type of data so first of all you have
source data this is data that's
typically persistent and you need to
load up when you start up your pipeline
and here what's really important is very
high throughput so you want a
collocation between your workers and
your data so region and dual region
makes sense the second type is
intermediate data and here this one's a
little bit interesting this is data
that's produced by one stage of your
pipeline and consumed by the next and it
doesn't actually always make sense to
use GCS here we've actually found a lot
of users who need higher throughput
lower latency and this data is very
short-lived and so sometimes using
something like local SSD makes sense
there are also sometimes specialized
services like a shuffle service that you
can get higher performance
the third type of data is what I call
side inputs and staging data so this is
data that's typically read once per
worker it's loaded all up together but
then after that's never read again and
here the the type of location doesn't
really matter that much and the reason
why is that GCS ends up doing a lot of
caching behind the scenes and so you're
fetching the same data over and over so
even if it's remote the first time
subsequent times are typically nice and
fast and then finally there's final
outputs you know what is your your
pipeline actually produce and here the
location type in storage class really
depends on what you're gonna do with the
final output so if you're if you're
producing say process images that you're
gonna serve out to Internet users you'd
probably want to use the advice that
Jeff gave on content serving and choose
a storage class based off of that if
instead this is going to be data that's
going to be fed into another pipeline
then it would it would end up acting
like source data again and you would
want to use regional or dual regional I
wanted to give a quick blurb because
we've been seeing a lot of interest in
using moving Hadoop workloads to the
cloud and so I wanted to give a shout
out to our Cloud Data proc service which
is a managed dupe service and lets you
bring up clusters very very quickly and
we also have a connector that allows you
to access your your source data and your
final outputs directly from GCS without
having to load it first into HDFS so you
can save a bit of time by skipping that
step there are a couple of gotchas
object storage is not a file system so
we don't have directory semantics today
so you're gonna want to work around
those and eliminate your dependency on
atomic directory operations so for
example one common pattern that we see
is that you might write data temporarily
into a temporary directory and then when
your data set is complete you'll rename
it to a final directory and a
alternative approach is to go ahead and
write that into the final directory and
when your data set is complete write a
sentinel file that says hey I'm done
with the data I'll talk a little bit in
a bit on performance but you're gonna
see that obvious Orage is going to have
higher latency overall come
to HDFS and so you're gonna want a favor
parallelization to get around that and
then finally like I already mentioned
you may want to use local SSD for
temporary data okay
so let's now talk about some performance
and scaling tips which I think are
really applicable across multiple use
cases so I think the first thing to
understand is is a general performance
characteristics of object storage and
the TLDR is that that latency for small
objects is relatively high so at 95th
percentile you might expect like a one
byte read to take about 100 milliseconds
give or take it depends a bit on the
hotness of the object but around 100
milliseconds and similarly for writes on
the flip side I think we're our
strengths are are of course horizontal
scalability and then single stream
throughput so with a object that's large
enough you should be able to get about
800 megabits or about 100 megabytes per
second and for writes you can get about
400 megabits per second so what this
means is that you're gonna really want
to try to favor larger object sizes if
you have if you have options in terms of
how to pack your data
don't shard them unnecessarily try to
keep the objects relatively large
because you can see on the graph on the
right you're not really able to take
advantage of the single stream
throughput until you get to larger
object sizes similarly even if you are
able to pack all your data into larger
objects you may have internal if you
have structured data you may have
internal segments or pages and if you
can you want to tune those to be a
little bit larger we recommend about 2
megabytes if you can go larger it's even
better but you're gonna have to sort of
a trade-off between how much you read at
once and how much effort is wasted
depending on your query and then like I
mentioned earlier sometimes you can't
create larger objects you have no you
have no choice and that's ok just make
sure you paralyze so that you you work
around the inherit latency that's in the
service and that you can you can
increase your throughput that way so
next let's talk a little bit about
writing objects and how to get the best
performance out of writes
there's actually three high-level
strategies you can use for writes the
simplest one is just a non resume will
upload
you use your single requests you upload
your entire object the second strategy
is to do what we call resumable upload
so we have a protocol where you first
send a request to initiate a new
resumable upload session and you get
back a unique session ID and then you
issue a second request where you upload
your your data and hopefully that
succeeds but if it fails what you can
end up doing is you can query the server
and say hey what was less offset that
you were successfully able to commit and
once you have that offset you can then
issue another upload request and only
upload the bytes that the server hasn't
received the third approach is parallel
upload so you can upload you can you can
split your object in two parts you can
upload them and then you can do a
compose the compose operation is a
metadata only operation so it it's
constant time it doesn't rewrite any of
the bytes and if you if you have your
entire object up front you can of course
split it upfront and upload those parts
you know you can get the sharding done
right away if you're doing a streaming
approach and you don't know what the
final object sizes you can iteratively
chunk your buffer upload that in chunks
compose and then do it again for the
next set of bytes in your buffer so I
think you know obviously you want to use
non resumable uploads by default but I
think what's not really always clear is
how high of a bar you want to use before
you switch over a resumable upload
resumable uploads have several
disadvantages one of the big ones is
that they require a minimum of two
requests and if you imagine that that
first request takes something on the
order of say 100 milliseconds that means
for small objects that hundred
milliseconds is a large part of the
overall upload time so say it's a large
amount of overhead so the general rule
of thumb I like to use is take your
expected throughput multiply it by about
30 seconds and that's a reasonable
cutoff time for for the object size
before you want to switch over to
resumable uploads what that means is
that you're gonna lose at most 30
seconds of effort if something goes
wrong and things go wrong very rarely
usually it also means that as you hit
that 30-second threshold the amount of
overhead
that that first requests ads is
relatively small less than half a
percent right and so to give some
concrete numbers if you have clients
that are using say cable cable modem
access and they have a four megabit per
second upload speed then the cutoff is
gonna be about 15 megabytes similarly if
you have a VM that's you know on our
network you're getting the full form
negatives per second you shouldn't
really be even considering resume
uploads tell about you know over a gig
or so so it's fairly large objects
before you you really want to care about
this and then finally if resumable
uploads have a high bar I would say
parallel let's have an even higher bar
you really only want there's a lot of
additional complexity that that you add
with this so it's it's not something you
want to do lightly you should really
only do this if you are you know
uploading from a VM and you really need
greater than 400 megabits per second
that typically means you're talking on
very very large object sites right
tens of gigabytes or more there is one
other use case which is that certain
connections have relatively high
bandwidth but a relatively high delay
and due to the way TCP works you
sometimes are not able to fill your pipe
in those cases sometimes having multiple
connections is beneficial okay so next I
want to talk about retries it sounds a
little bit dry but it's actually has a
big impact on both the reliability and
the performance that you're gonna get so
right here I have a pretty typical retry
strategy it's exponential back-off we
have a loop you know we make a call
there's a dead line if there's a retrial
error we back off exponentially then we
give up afterwards after a fixed number
of attempts so there's I think two
tricky things to consider here so first
of all right now with every attempt
we're reassuring the same requests and
so there's a question of is that the
right strategy for getting the best
reliability the second question is we
have this deadline so what's the right
deadline you know if you do too short or
too long that has impact on performance
or reliability so let's look into those
one-by-one so first of all I think the
key thing with retries is you really
want to be failing over if at all
possible so this is sort of a simplified
you know view of what
Sorge might look like in this
implementation we have a set of front
ends they're running on multiple servers
and they're stateless so you can really
hit any of those servers then we have a
set of meditative servers and those are
stateful and so for any given object you
need to go to a specific subset of those
servers and similarly we have data
servers and you can only use a specific
subset so those are represented in blue
so imagine a user makes a request for a
specific object it hits one of the front
ends it hits one of the midea servers
it's one of the data servers and
something goes wrong well if the error
happens if the meditator data level then
cloud storage is going to take care of
retrying automatically and it's going to
fail over to the alternate replicas so
this should all happen under the hoods
so that's great because it it means
we're not retrying the same unhealthy
node right the problem is what happens
if the front-end itself is unhealthy
naive retry strategy would end up
reusing the same TCP connection or the
same HTTP connection and you'll end up
hitting the same unhealthy front-end
right so it's pretty important that when
you do your retry make sure you're
actually opening up a new connection our
load balancing will typically send that
to a different server and you're
unlikely and that'll cause proper
failover so let's also talk about
deadlines now I mentioned that it's too
short or too long there's there's
repercussions so if you're setting a
deadline that's too short the biggest
problem is that you might be prematurely
cancelling or failing a request that
could have succeeded if you were just
willing to wait a little bit longer and
that ends up driving up your error rate
artificially it ends up wasting work
right similarly if you set a deadline
that's too long the problem is that you
may sit around waiting too long for
requests that's never going to succeed
and if you had just retried a little
earlier you could have really cut down
that latency right so so what do you do
well we recommend doing is a technique
called hedge requests the problem with
the previous algorithm is that each
attempt had to run individually they
couldn't run in parallel so if you
instead issue your retries in parallel
what that allows you to do is each
individual attempt can have a
long dead line so that you know we wait
for a long enough time in case the whole
service is down is slow and at the same
time you can shorten the delay before
issuing that second request so that you
can really cut down on your tail agency
so let me walk I can walk through this a
little bit more detail to hopefully make
it more clear
so imagine use you issue you your
initial attempt and it's taking a little
while to come back it in fact it so it's
a little beyond normal one one good way
to implement this is to track what your
typical p95 latency is say over the last
minute or two and so you can you wait
and you haven't received a response
after hitting your p95 latency so what
you can go ahead and do is issue that
retry that second attempt but don't
cancel the first one let it keep going
right and if this is a scenario where
that first attempt happened to hit a
slow node and it's just taking a while
and the second tab fails over properly
then you'd expect that second attempt to
succeed pretty quickly and so you've
really cut down your latency quite a bit
right if on the other hand let's suppose
this first request was taking a long
time not because you hit a by a single
slow node but maybe the service is
having issues overall well because
you've set a long deadline for each of
these requests you didn't cancel that
first one and so that allows that first
request to succeed it will be of course
slow but at least we're not wasting work
or throwing away or causing errors
pretty mature Lee so that's head request
and I wanted to throw out two other
things because I think are pretty
important especially if you do use head
requests I think the the first one is is
to make sure to limit your retry volume
and of course this helps us the service
we you know from from getting slammed
when things aren't healthy but also
helps your client and if you notice in
the previous hedge request slides I I
suggested you waiting for the p95
latency before issue in the head
requests that means in steady-state
you're only issuing about 5% extra
traffic right but the problem is that
latency can temporarily spike if a
temporary spikes then you could be
issuing up to 100% extra traffic
and so limiting your we travel into a
smaller subset say 10% is generally a
good practice the other thing that to be
careful about with retries is making
sure you have item potent sequences this
is something that we've seen a few
different users forget about and it can
cause serious problems like data loss so
I thought it was worth going to that
really quickly to explore that so a non
unimportant sequence is a sequence of
operations where if you repeat the
entire sequence or a subsequence you may
it's item potent if you always end up
with the same state it's not an
idempotent if it's possible to end up in
a different state so here's an example
of a non unimportant sequence imagine we
create an object X and that creates a
generation number one then we issue a
delete operation which deletes it and
then we followed up by creating a new
version of that object
so let's generation number two so this
shows what happens in that sort of
normal case where no errors occur so
here's an example of what can happen if
an error occurs and you issue a retry so
imagine the the initial creates exceeds
your initial delete request takes a long
time and so you timeout all right and
when you timeout you issue that retry
and that retry succeeds
so now you've deleted generation number
one you then go ahead and create the
object again and you've created
generation number two and the problem is
is that very first delete attempt even
though you timed it out on the client
side it was actually stuck in one of the
buffers in our server one of the queues
in our server and so it does end up
getting applied and ends up leading the
generation to object that you just
created so this is a data loss scenario
so you really want to make sure that
your sequences are idempotent to avoid
this type of problem one one way of
doing that is use preconditions so in
this example we can really make sure
rather than saying delete object X we
can say delete object X generation one
only and that ensures that that dark
request that came in afterwards or that
finished afterwards gets cancelled
because it's no longer relevant to the
current generation of the object which
is generation two there are other ways
of doing this
another common technique for doing this
is to simply never overwrite objects
with new content right so you can write
once and if you have to have to rewrite
so if we write in the same content okay
finally I wanted to end and talked a
little bit about scaling and and hot
spotting and generally speaking just get
scaling is something that cloud storage
does pretty well you don't typically
have to worry about your data size or
then the object can't we just scale
horizontally usually without worry
but there's one case that we have seen a
lot of folks get tripped up on and that
is localized hot spotting which can also
result in scaling bottlenecks as well
and so I wanted to give a little bit of
intuition and background for what's
happening under the hoods and then some
advice on on how to work around this so
cloud storage uses a scaling or sharding
strategy called range based charting and
so what that means is we of course store
your objects on multiple servers and the
way we assign objects of servers is we
split up our object name space into
ranges so in this example an object
starting with C would go into that first
shard and objects starting with M would
go into the second shard and we chose
the strategy for a very specific purpose
which is to provide consistent listing
right so imagine a user issues a request
to list every object starting with T
slash in order to fill this request it's
pretty simple the request needs to get
routed to a single shard this s shard
and that shard is sufficient to to
service the entire request we know that
there are no objects starting with T and
any of the other shards so let's look at
an alternative approach to what we could
have done right the alternative approach
is to do something like hash based
charting when you take the object name
you hash it and then you assign it to
one of the shards based off of the hash
and that really distributes the objects
all over the place so this same listing
operation now what happens
in order to service a request you have
to look at every single shard right
because you don't know where the T star
T slash objects are gonna be and what
happens if a shard is slow you have to
wait for it so as a number of shards
increases you're going to hit that tail
agency your overall listing latency is
gonna it's gonna go up right perhaps
even worse what happens if one of the
shards fails then you're stuck with a
sort of poor choice you can either
return incomplete results or you can
fail you the overall request and again
as a number of shards increases your if
assuming you're failing the overall
request your chance of success goes way
down so because of this hash-based
sharding really doesn't scale well when
you're trying to revive is strongly
consistent listing and so we've gone
with range based charting so of course
one of your shards can get hot and we we
do Auto scale and we detect that and we
split those shards you know in half or
more and to try to distribute load and I
wanted to give a feel for when this
becomes an issue you should expect about
a thousand objects object rights per
second about 5000 wheels per second
there that's probably a little bit
conservative but that's roughly what you
can expect for any given shard and then
when a shorty gets hot we try to split
ahead of time so that you don't notice
things but you can expect a delay of
about 20 minutes if you are slamming a
particularly short that's also again
probably little bit conservative but I
think it's good to keep in mind because
this is about when you're gonna run into
these type of problems right and in
order for this to work well I think the
key thing is to make sure your
distribute your load evenly if you have
nice consistent even load then we can
really detect shards getting hot and we
can split them well ahead of that and
becoming a problem so there's one common
pattern that essentially trips up a lot
of a lot of uses so and that's
sequential access and and let's go
through why this is problematic
so by sequential access I mean you know
reading or writing objects in order of
their name right in lexicographical
order
and in this example we have g h i j k so
pretty simple and you can see that these
accesses are distributed across two
range based shards but the biggest
problem here is that even though overall
the accesses are distribute across the
street shards if you take a look at any
particular time range it's always laser
in one shard at a time so you don't
actually get the scaling properties of
having two different shards you're
you're really bound by the limit of a
single shard right so that's that's what
we mean by hot spotting you're really
lasering this one shard you know a
potential way around this is to go ahead
and say okay well let's split si shards
up into smaller ranges right and this
definitely does help spread the load but
it causes fragmentation and
fragmentation is a problem again because
of consistent listing right previously
with a low fragmentation the list
operation can hit a relatively few
number of shards with high fragmentation
you end up having to hit many shards and
you start running into the same late and
tail agency and availability problems
that you would get with hash-based
sharding so this is I want to go through
this because this is sort of a
fundamental trade-off that you have to
make and it's it's pretty difficult to
get around this so here are some common
naming patterns that we see that causes
type of sequential access so one of them
is using year-month-day you know you see
this a lot with like writing logs for
example you also see things like having
order numbers or user IDs that are
sequential just counting up
monotonically and then similarly we also
see a use of timestamp so these are
three common patterns that we see that
can cause problems there are a couple
ways you can work around this if you
need to and again I wanted to rehab size
it really only becomes a palm after a
thousand writes per second or five
thousand reasons per second so
oftentimes this is an issue one of the
things you can do is I'm just call like
manually partitioning your prefixes so
in this example we pulled the log type
upfront right and that means that if I'm
processing a single day across multiple
log types I'm going to
end up hitting multiple prefixes at once
and I'm gonna get a fixed multiplication
of the sharding right the second
approach is to just don't use the
question IDs if you don't have to right
so for order numbers if you don't really
need that count of the number of orders
for example just using UID and that'll
spread load more evenly the third
approach is you can end up taking a hash
of your object name and putting that
into your prefix right and so in this
pretty example I didn't hash the entire
name but I hashed a timestamp tonight I
put that up front and this gives you
really good even load-balancing the big
drawback is that you no longer get in
order listing right so this again so
this only works if you don't really need
to list in order and finally there's an
alternative that you can do it that's a
little bit in between you can hash and
then map it to a fixed number of shards
and what this ends up allowing you to do
is it allows you to preserve the inorder
listing by issuing ten listing
operations in parallel one Ds shard and
merging the results so it's extra work
but if inorder listing is absolutely
something you need and you also need to
get around the scaling limitations this
is an approach that you can take finally
I wanted to mention all the previous
alternatives I'm exigent were around
naming you don't always have to actually
change a name in the case of bulk
operations you can simply make sure that
your axis is spread evenly in randomly
so for example if I'm running a batch
job across my entire corpus I could have
the different workers process different
directories simultaneously and that
would cause more even load you can also
choose randomly choose which objects a
process and then I'll distribute the
load a little bit more evenly as well so
with that those are the you know
hopefully you found it useful that's
that's the main tips that we want to
provide today we didn't cover a lot of
other areas I know there's a lot of tips
in security there's a lot of tips around
archival so I wanted to give a quick
plug we have
ten other stores talks that are ongoing
the ones in blue these are ones that
haven't been held yet so if you want to
catch them live and there they're
interesting to you I'd encourage you to
do that the ones that aren't highlighted
they've already happened but they should
be on YouTube pretty soon and so there's
there's good tips on you know for
example seeing how twitter is migrating
their their workload to us for a very
high intensity computer use case and
also how to do things like transferring
your data in so hopefully everyone found
that useful Jeff and I are gonna hang
out afterwards and we're happy to answer
questions that you might have so thank
you
[Music]